The very last scene of The Last Jedi garnered
gasps from packed theaters across the globe.
Yep: that little boy used the Force to guide
a broom into his hand before pausing from
his work to stare into space, daydreaming
about the Resistance.
Who is that little boy and what exactly did
that mean?
And more importantly, what does the scene
mean for the future of Star Wars?
Let's break down what could potentially be
the most important scene in The Last Jedi—and
be forewarned, there are more spoilers ahead.
He's a slave
To provide a little refresher, one of The
Last Jedi's plots sees Finn and Rose traveling
to the planet Cantonica to find a hacker in
the city of Canto Bight.
The casino city—more Monaco than Las Vegas—is
the ultimate hangout for the wealthy.
But that doesn't tell the whole story.
As Rose points out, drawing on her own painful
past, the people working in Canto Bight are
slaves.
It's during this sequence that we first encounter
the boy in one of the stables as Finn and
Rose escape—he's among the child slaves
that clean and sleep in the stables while
caring for the Fathiers, the space ponies
who end up serving as Finn and Rose's way
out.
We know his name
The Star Wars: The Last Jedi Visual Dictionary
tells us that the boy is named Temiri Blagg,
and according to IMDb, first-timer Temirlan
Blaev portrays the boy.
Clearly, Blagg is at the least Force sensitive,
and that's nothing to scoff at in the Star
Wars universe.
In fact, over the course of the current trilogy,
he's one of only a handful of people we've
seen use the Force—a list that includes
heavy hitters like Luke, Rey, Leia, Kylo Ren,
Snoke, and Yoda.
In other words, he's probably a big deal.
He's a nobody
Aside from offering up some of the coolest
space battles and most exciting action sequences
in the franchise, The Last Jedi put a lot
of effort into shaking up the Star Wars mythology—which
is another way of saying that a lot of what
we thought we knew about the saga just went
out like trash from a Star Destroyer.
Rey, the powerful Force-sensitive hero of
the new trilogy, turns out not to be the secret
offspring of one of the story's heavy hitters.
In fact, her parents were basically space
trash.
In the new Star Wars universe, you don't have
to be a Skywalker or a Kenobi to be important.
Along those lines, Temiri Blagg doesn't appear
to be related to anyone you've heard of; his
parents abandoned him, just as Rey's parents
left her.
As the Skywalker saga comes to a close, we're
learning that anyone can be Force-sensitive,
from a daughter of drunkards to a slave boy
who sweeps up Fathier scat.
He won't be a Jedi
Kylo Ren spelled out the new plan for the
movies going forward—no more Jedi, no more
Sith.
Temiri Blagg is Force sensitive, and he might
do something with it, but he won't be a Jedi,
because the order as it existed is gone.
Rey isn't one, at least as it's been traditionally
defined, so as far as we know there aren't
any Jedi left to teach him.
And yes, the Jedi sacred books survived—stowed
away by Rey on the Millennium Falcon—but
studying from a book is very different from
the master/padawan dynamic built up over generations
of Jedi.
He could be a New Hope
As Luke vowed before becoming one with the
Force in the final act, he won't be the last
Jedi—but what it means to be one, and who
gets to carry that mantle going forward, is
wide open.
It likely wasn't a coincidence that The Last
Jedi ended with Blagg staring off into a star
cluster, uncertain of his future, just as
Luke did at the end of The Empire Strikes
Back.
You could make the case that Blagg is the
new Luke—without the pedigree, and without
the promise of proper Jedi training.
Or maybe he isn't?
Then again, the odds of Temiri Blagg being
the only other Force-sensitive character besides
Rey in that galaxy far, far away is pretty
slim, and that also plays into the new Star
Wars canon.
Blagg won't be the only one—there will be
others.
Maybe he never makes it off Cantonica?
Maybe he doesn't pop up in Episode 9?
Both of those scenarios would fit into what
Star Wars is now: a brand new series, where
anyone can use the Force, and the Sith and
Jedi as we knew them are no more.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!